bill how are you what's going on oh
thank you thank you all seven of you and
the four kevin harts yeah
is he in the black section of the crowd
yeah it seems like
they've moved up to the middle progress
i like it there you are look at billy
how are you you look like a [ __ ]
prize i stupid headphones to work here
something that'll work let me see if
these ones will work hold on a second no
they work good
my headphones aren't working for me
though oh
it's about me nick it's not about you
here here we go
all right so next i am second season the
deepest couch in sports entertainment a
lot of people think that uh they're
uncomfortable with my uh my um elevation
are you uncomfortable with it no i just
see all of your insecurities
in a giant desk
and then also you can't you can't
tell other people's kids not to do stuff
right so you got to kind of like be
loudly like hey he's climbing up on the
utility pole and kind of hope that
somebody does something
well back in the day you could yell at
people's kids and i think that that
needs to come back and that's what's
holding back this country
so it was very like we're very like you
know you wouldn't know that we like each
other let's let's try to tone it down no
no i'm not i'm just
no that's what happened i came right at
me just saying my theories stunk i'm
just here to promote a cartoon i'm a
dancing monkey today i'm trying to be a
good guy i want people to like me and
watch the show here and you're coming at
me i don't know anything about hoop i'm
a five foot ten inch white guy this dude
is knocking it out of the park he's one
of my favorites here is bill burr
look at me look at you oh
you know i shouldn't have to wear a mask
i don't want to wear a mask i don't buy
it and then there are people that um i
love those people what you like the
people that flip out yeah don't wear it
yeah don't wear it go kill yourself
that's awesome cause i have to be honest
with you i know a lot of people died
from covid but i'm starting to see the
traffic come back and uh i selfishly
thought i wish it killed a few more
i have always kind of been slightly
dubious of a comedy competition though
you know you don't need confidence
you can't get up there and just do your
dick jokes better than other people oh
no i can't i feel i feel like it's not
the right way to go about it all you
have to do is be louder than someone
else oh i can do you flap your hands
around
you're guaranteed to make the finals i
built a whole career
at some point i was going to make a
point here that's why i keep looking at
here and i just realized i'm blocking
myself out of the camera i love that you
have the jib camera for this like it's
an action movie
let's let's let's swoop in at these two
guys sitting in these unbelievably small
chairs
i literally feel like i'm gonna fall
onto the floor this is insane
you really went all out with the
audience though they got full-sized
adult chairs
are these like from the 20s before they
had like horse tranquilizers in our food
when everybody was like five foot one
i fly a lot and there's this whole new
thing of generation of people that take
their socks and their shoes off on the
plane you got to look at their smelly
feet and then they'll literally stand up
and they will walk into a commercial
airline bathroom
yeah use it and then walk and sit back
down again that's not right yeah if i
was a dictator those people would be
eliminated
a lot coming from the hillary clinton
camp that trump is bad for children and
they had a lot of ads that said you know
children are watching this guy oh we all
know that children five and six years
old they're always tuning into the
debates
taking notes that's what i did when i
was a kid i'll never forget that
i'm going to tell you how i discovered
you
i you know i i do my whole career to you
yeah
i was like i was struggling until
obviously i covered
that not discover you in terms of like
you did it on your own obviously but no
in terms of my my awareness of you
oh can i tell you that story i remember
it was a big day in my career
bobby lee is finally aware of me
am i on bobby lee's radar see this is
what he's gonna this is when things
start to happen i'm not gonna allow this
to that reversal i'm not yeah i'm not
gonna allow this to happen very soon
yeah yeah i'm just gonna plug away you
know what i mean listen you can talk to
him all you want
i can hear it
so are you in the i cannot get
comfortable in this [ __ ] chair this
is just like one of the worst things
this should be like at a museum is like
the prototype this is what
this was the awful level of comfort we
went from a log to this and then
eventually they got cushions
there's another guy looking at his phone
i swear to god
through the day jesus comes back if he
ever does if he's even a real person
like 90 of people are gonna miss it
they're gonna walk right he's gonna be
walking on water and immediately walking
by him they're not even gonna see it
long story short hugh jackman plays the
part of uh gary hart and he was he was
amazing and i had a really fun scene
where we were tailing him we were
chasing him down this alley and he's
like the nicest guy ever but he's a big
guy he's like 640 he's ripped and we
went down the alley and he and his
characters mattered our character and he
just turned around and looked at us and
for half a second i was like oh that's
wolverine
and i i literally
i legit got scared
and
he's a big guy you know so
what's funny in the scene is is as a
reporter i have like a notebook and i
dropped it
and after the screening we went to the
toronto film festival and all these
actors are coming up to me i love the
choice you made i love the choice you
made to drop the notebook i go no dude
that was real i was like
like there's a danger to buying that car
that big yell they see that big yellow
prancing pony and they just come out
they come up out of the manhole covers
all these gold diggers
like like a zombie movie
that is a gold digger magnet and they
are so good at it they can look and tell
if it's rented or not they know where to
look for the sticker i don't know how to
do that
oh there we go no but now this is like
the ego one now i'm gonna be sitting
above you you gotta come with two
it's fine that's right sir the one
the one comedy through line that's
working here is me [ __ ] on this
chair why would you take that for me
this is you're just totally going
against the grain
i understand it but you got on camera so
i think you get paid even though this is
online
guys every time i go into a store and i
see something they go can we get a phone
number watching somebody give them the
phone number why would you do that yeah
i always give the same i mine is all
area codes they go what's your phone
number i'm like three two three eight
one eight two one two five
we've never taken a break in the middle
of a gas station i know i had all this
momentum going on i got to start all
over again
go ahead go to the card
see this
we won game one
here comes the second of the double
header
is that a rolex yes it is i finally
bought one 25 years in this business is
it white gold or stainless i don't know
what it is is it heavy
no then it's stainless oh is that what
it is thank you thank you for taking my
watch down a notch i finally felt
successful you see this you wouldn't say
that if i had brown or black hair i
guarantee you blonde hair you'd be over
here giving me your watch
you really are the whitest person i've
ever seen yes
served me well i've never worked for
anything
yeah i was born on a yacht
it's just all been downhill i don't even
mean it and i don't mean it in in a a
genetic way i mean like i do you i'm
talking full-on white privilege
i was stunned when i first heard about
white privilege i had no idea what it
was it's like everybody doesn't get to
do this
it seems as if the song never job
being a mother is the hardest job out
the most difficult job and if oprah said
that oprah said that yeah has that has
your opinion on that on that phrase
changed at all since you had a kid
no
[Laughter]
it's not the most difficult job on the
planet
it just isn't
dude i did roofing in july i almost as a
redhead i almost died
there's people
there's people that work on like oil
what was that movie that guy made the
oil the [ __ ] you know they grow oil
what is it there will be blood there
will be blood the uh out in the ocean
they would drill i can never remember
their names
mark wahlberg
horizon yeah yeah those guys were
working on on an oil rig the [ __ ]
thing blows up
they're on fire they gotta jump into
water that's on fire
salty water into their wounds you gotta
swim out of that oil and fire and then
tread water
praying to god that the coast guard is
gonna get there before the sharks do
now talk to me about a toddler oh he was
so fussy today i just
he wouldn't eat his peas
yeah and just the level of reward that
is you know as annoying as a kid is like
they smile at you and it's over it's
over so i mean you don't get that you
know working on an oil rig when your
buddy's greasy face lights up
you know what it really is all worth it
i love the racist white guy thing a
bunch of racist white guys they came out
of the forest and they were just going
trump trump trump
it's like where were all these racist
white guys the last two elections when
they could have voted against the black
guy they were fine oh i don't mind the
black guy but this white lady we got to
stop her
he's going to take a four-wheeler so
your christian background is is part of
the the show yes and i wanted to talk to
you about jesus after that well
the other reason why i bring it up but
some people thought maybe you went a
little too far you know as far as what
well they thought that maybe you were
being disrespectful to the christian
religion
i'm telling you you need to google
oh good lord so did you feel you were
disrespectful or just you you were just
having fun with some of the crucifixes
and
stuff like that
i don't even know what yeah i mean we
did maybe two jokes about that yeah
exactly don't you think the catholic
church went a little too far
more so than my cartoon all right listen
a couple of jokes i know this is a
morning show you can't bring up all
those crimes you know what they just
they just sort of kept moving them
around you know like those killer whales
at sea world after it kills a trainer
they'll then move it up to seattle they
don't give them their background
all right i'm not totally following
but i don't think you know what i'm
talking about it's a morning show i
understand
that kid was missed the graduation and
then it was a feel-good story
and we want to leave if you want to feel
good about america you watch the morning
shows you don't watch this you know and
one i was joking earlier if that kid's
story about the graduation was late
night that would have been a whole
different story what do you think he's
still missing we can't find him all we
found was his hat but you watch in the
morning it's great it all worked out he
got his own personal graduation like i
was in such a great mood look how yellow
this couch is it's like the sun but what
did you say about the military that got
people so mad or this one guys i was
just saying like yeah the guy who flies
the fighter jet okay and has missile
shot and that guy's a hero however if
you're the guy that like points in the
direction that the plane takes off in
you know what i mean hey this is south
side steve and this is southside steve
tv and this is bill burr
that's your question
i'm just saying who you are oh yeah all
right i don't like you creep me out with
that big microphone in that country
western shirt oh no this isn't country
western
it's like it's hip now to wear this this
is my nightclub look yeah come on
all right
this is this is i guess this is the
internet right you just sort of just
throw it out there i just throw it out
there i figure you're a funny guy
i'll throw it out there too well here's
the deal bill's a comedian he's at the
punch line he's in town and you're a
funny guy you've got these routines in
your head so i figure i'll toss you mike
and you go
and i'm gonna do stand up in front of
nine people in a radio station no i'm
not doing that well you're taking the
fun out of south side steve tv
uh how about i give you five bucks i
want to watch you line dance and you're
i'm a racist
you just had the baby yeah little uh
friday morning
i didn't i didn't my wife did i didn't
uh
i didn't do anything i felt unbelievably
useless
i was in total panic mode when i dropped
her up at the emergency room she goes
all right you got to go park the car
down in the in the in the spot and i
swear to god i was in such fight or
flight i was i was driving down there
this voice my head just said just keep
going just keep going just drive away of
course i wouldn't but i started laughing
isn't that like a bruce springsteen song
about that going out to get cigarettes
and you just there's something hilarious
about people abandoning their family
we're like i just can't imagine
like the hell that you would be in to do
that move
but just knowing you're gonna do it like
the level of excitement that you would
have before like okay i'm gonna uh
i'm gonna go get some cigarettes
i'm never gonna see you people again
your mother-in-law all of this stuff is
over
you never saw weird science how creepy
these nerds are all these cameras on
your phone all of that do people go on
ancestry.com
why would you send your saliva into the
internet why would you do that
why don't you just go to the illuminati
and help them build your robot
replacement
but do you like my mic no i don't i
don't please is that comfortable is this
uncomfortable this is yeah no don't man
honestly can i can i take the mic sure
now that's number the number one thing
you don't do
as i learned that in broadcasting school
you never give up the microphone see now
i have the power
this bob barker thing yeah you're uh
what is this rock one of 100.5 this is
the worst interview i've ever done and
he's wearing stetson cologne or
something it's just really
over overpowering
you know what he looks like he looks
like the first guy who gets his ass
kicked in a steven seagal movie
the background guy behind the uh the big
kingpin wouldn't you handle this
conspiracy theory has gotten a bad name
where now it's it's it's become
synonymous with like moronic thought
like if you're into conspiracy theory if
you think like the bankers need to be
stopped and you also think the moon is
made out of cheese
and you think that the shapeshift
shifters and like lizard people
you know they just try to knock it down
it's like this country started with a
conspiracy that's how it came we won
so they're considered heroes and rebels
you know whatever revolutionaries but if
they lost
they would be hanged for conspire for
conspiring yeah it's not like it
spontaneously happened yeah like all of
a sudden everybody just picked up a gun
and started shooting at the british you
know they sat around they said they
planned it out planned it out i'm kind
of getting tired of these people
it's funny when you said we when i'm
like did we really win but i don't know
what you're saying i understand what
you're saying now is that that
african-american thing yeah
you're whatever incognito you're an
enigma
what because i make a pie no you know
what it is you're not a good listener
you've known me for 10 years you have no
idea who i am it's all about comedy with
you and moving up the ladder pushing
people
is this are you getting out of an
existing house and uh i'm going from a
one-bedroom apartment and i figured i'd
finally go out and buy a damn house
and not have to deal with you know some
jerk living above me or below me all
right you know yeah do my own little
thing get my little 12 gauge get a bunch
of cans of tuna get ready for the
apocalypse that's what i want to do but
is that were you
were you funnier or was it just you
enjoyed the difficulty more i mean i
don't know if it makes you funnier
because it's a harder show to do or it's
more i don't either i don't either but i
will say that what i liked about it was
was that uh
that you know just that those years we
just like you know so much of your
stand-up career is just one impossible
situation after another and you just
standing there trying to do the math
like how the [ __ ] am i going to get
these people we don't have a microphone
is that going to be a problem can you do
10 minutes while the band changes yeah
no i can't they're just going to take
the instruments off and on the stage no
that's not oh yeah that's doing it
they're coming in they're tuning up
done gigs in the hallways yeah hallways
areas that met in a hallway cafeterias
during at like one in the afternoon sure
college kids have no idea there's going
to be a show and they just go we have a
comedian his name is bill burr here he
is
and then you just walk up there and have
to do an hour
hour i know of humiliation i would
always say to myself i'd always say in
an hour and one minute this is going to
be over
and i'm going to be in my car driving
away and that's what i would do and then
and and the part that i hated was the
waiting to go on yeah i still do once
you go on yeah it's the hourglass has
been turned over yeah the sand starting
to fall and every second you're up there
whatever hit you take that's one less
one you got to take no it's true i used
to always call it my college agent
afterwards flipping out going i'm
[ __ ] done with these things i'm never
[ __ ] doing this again i don't give a
[ __ ] he'd be like all right all right
all right and then he knew i needed the
money
then he called me up me like he'd be
like billy
scott bass that was my agent scott bass
cowling i know
you said you're not gonna do this but i
i i do have a nooner i'm gonna build
around it
and you know by then i'd be at home
and i cooled off it was a couple weeks
later from being on the road and the
rent was coming i needed the money
and he would be like all right it's
going to pay 700 bucks it's like the
middle of iowa for 700 bucks all
inclusive